freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ihr seht kein persönlicher
cox hat trotzdem was wir kochen zu tun
und zwar machen wir heute die beste
pizza der welt wir das sind luca und ich
luca ist aktuell noch auf dem rückweg
aus stuttgart kommt aber dann gleich zu
mir und dann machen wir zusammen die
pizza ich habe ein bisschen was schon
vorbereitet ich habe vor fast 24 stunden
angefangen diesen tag hier zu machen und
wie sagen wir fangen in dem jetzt 220
milliliter warmes wasser in die schüssel
geben dazu einen halben teelöffel
backpulver das backpulver lösen wir in
dem warmen wasser auf und fügen 350
gramm mehl zucker verrühren wir jetzt
erstmal mit einer gabel und sobald das
einigermaßen verwirrt ist fangen wir an
mit den händen zu kneten finds gut
durchgeknetet ist dann packen wir s ab
und lassen es im raum stehen und zwar
für zwölf stunden das heißt ich habe das
am vorabend angefangen und jetzt geht's
am nächsten morgen weiter
die zutaten sind genau die gleichen
mengen wie eben und der teig ist auf
jeden fall schon ordentliche aufgegangen
die wir jetzt das warme wasser darüber
dazu kommt dann mehr seit 18 gramm das
lösen wir im wasser auf und dann kommt
anschließend was mir dazu dass verkneten
wird es vorsichtig es wird auf jeden
fall ziemlich kleben wir hier sehen
könnt ich hab das ganze 45 minuten
geknetet oder so und dann bleibt es für
20 minuten stehen denn die 20 minuten
vorbei sind kommt der teig auf einer
bemehlten arbeitsfläche wird auch von
oben noch gemailt und wird durchgeknetet
also so gefaltet und geknetet
gleichzeitig wieder so 45 minuten an
wollen wir eine schüssel mit olivenöl
formen eine kleine kugel aus dem teig
geben ihn hinein und lassen ihn für drei
stunden stehen
das ganze haufen arbeit ich habe jetzt
hier meinen teil der sich nochmals
deutlich vergrößert hat das richtig
gesehen der war kein einziges mal im
kühlschrank oder so alles bei
raumtemperatur also da ich hole jetzt
den teig auf so der 56 prozent
feuchtigkeit also klassische
politisch werden wir machen wir noch
mechanisch spitze also wurde zeigt auch
vorsichtig habe auch die arbeitsfläche
aber man merkt wirklich dass es ein sehr
feucht datei ist 65 prozent feuchtigkeit
hat der bund ist deutlich größer als zu
beginn und leute er nicht wirklich gut
serviert besteuern jetzt auch die
oberfläche des teigs mitwählen
so wird das gemacht ist reif wir das
ganze ein bisschen dass das
gleichmäßiger ist machen wir übrigens
damit er nicht klebt jetzt vierten teil
zeigte führte ein pudding schmeling kann
weitergehen abmontiert die teig fertig
und drückt von unten so hinein geben
diese im kreis herum und bieten damit
eine kugel komplett datei ist eine
schöne glatte oberfläche entsteht
einfach unten rein drücken teilt sich
gezeigt habe ist übrigens für vier
plätzen die frage ob sich das
nachzumachen weil gebraucht halt den
speziellen ofen die extra für dieses
video gekauft habe um die temperaturen
zu erzielen die eine napolitan ische
gebraucht wird schon schöne kugel dann
kann man das ganze ein bisschen auf den
tisch drehen und die haben ein schönes
teig bällchen für unseren ticker boden
ja ich so kleine behältnisse
vorgefertigt mit olivenöl bestrichen
dagegen jetzt einfach mit teig schön
mittig rein und dann dauert auch nicht
mehr lange dann kommt luca und dann
bewegen wir die pizzen und dann kommen
vor allem das wichtigste des gesamten
videos dass der test tags darauf bin ich
mich mit am meisten gespannt natürlich
und wir warten bei 42 stunden ich
bereite noch schnell die büffel
mozzarella vor
die habe ich auch im italienischen
supermarkt gekauft wir wissen die
mozzarella kugeln immer in wasser
ungern dass meine mutter so nass ist
deshalb lasse ich die ein bisschen
abtropfen und reiste sie in so kleinen
stückchen circa eine stunde bevor es los
geht und so lange dass das aufstehen und
jetzt werde ich nicht ob die tomatensoße
kümmern wie besteht einfach nur aus
italienischen como doris plat die also
geschälten tomaten wir öffnen diese dose
hier starten wir uns unseren mixa und
branchen die tomaten wir wollen sie
nicht zu klein haben wir geben zu dem
ganzen noch eine gute prise mehr zeit
sich diesen zu hause die ich hier würde
ich auch noch mal runter man das ein
bisschen vorsichtiger macht als legt
dann sieht das auch nicht so aus aber
das war schon das wenn unsere zutaten
für die besten fans der welt
ich kann es nicht erwarten ihr müsst
euch vorstellen ich hab nur für dieses
video einen pizzaofen gekauft nicht teil
er hat vielleicht die ein oder werbung
in dem video drin ist wo leute hier
draußen ist der ofen nicht ob mein grill
gestellt welche angst dass er heiß wird
würde aber gar nicht dieses langen
machen den ofen bis zu 600 grad heiß das
durch eine menge und auf diesem stein
beste pizza
luca ist ja ich habe auch
gebracht die schnellste pizza sobald man
doppelt so schnell ist dann perfekt und
das werden wir uns jeden tag glücklich
zeit habe ich vor knapp zwei jahren 24
stunden lang nehmen jetzt operiert
verletzt jemand so schnell was ich dann
selber machen ja hier füllt das ganze
ist schon so oft im thai boxen und nie
gut dass ich so ein bisschen jetzt auf
einmal da kommt der leute nehmen ihre
sache gibt die rückseite und die seitdem
er ja auch noch so wir fahren jetzt an
den rand zu formen
durch ein weit mehr menschen als
abschluss was die ganze kraft und sobald
es gemacht ist flippen wir auch schon
direkt die pizza
neben den möglichkeiten und kommen von
der gegenseite auch den rand und jetzt
drücken wir so von innen nach außen
ja wir machen uns zusammen schwarze die
weltspitze
15 15 wenn das gemacht ist detailreich
gehen wir so mit zwei fäusten rein
ausdrehen das ganze ohne zweifel dass
mir so schnell ich glaube wir sind schon
eigentlich auf den ziemlich guten weg
die piste traut alter bildform die ein
bisschen wilder genauso muss einen
pizzateig aussehen bro für den markt für
immer relativ häufig es ist so wie die
samt und jetzt
die tomaten 1000 teilen das ganze ich
habe genauso wie du glaube ich ich habe
tatsächlich gar nicht so viel weil ich
mir gerade 35 minuten rein geknallt war
den ganzen tag unterwegs bisher nur
brezeln und bananen und wasser gegessen
und sollte zu mir genommen und jetzt
gerade dahinter liegen jetzt mit
kulinarischen politik denkt sich auch
noch das jetzt wird stationsleiter das
nicht richtig fällt jetzt packen wir
darauf kommt luca dass ich nicht dabei
haben die täter aber super du bist
glaube ich auf youtube mit am meisten
dafür bekannt dass die pizza zu schätzen
weiß
bist du bereit alter gedacht die
persönlich abseitig kurs und das nicht
muss mit brille machen deutlich
schneller perfekt dass wir auch eine
mutter oder ein vater den räumen konnte
auf sich jetzt bald wieder streiks
weiter versucht das war nicht so klar
erster versuch das hier war kein versuch
ist einfach mal für seinen traum zu
gucken wie der oben muss er komplett rum
nein
ok jetzt so wie es nokia eigentlich so
perfekt effekt ist eine schande dass
alles war durch perfekte die pizza auf
dem blech lack daran
ich frage mich nur was
eine rolle sowie dann ist es ein pizza
experte fungiert sie natürlich auch zu
jetzt komm person mehr drauf auch wenn
dann von unten vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr ich ist das wieder drauf und sie
rutscht das gut dass der wunsch dass
dieselben kommt vorschnell alter wie
wild es hat einfach lieber klassisch
denn man muss auf jeden fall ganze band
gut im blick behalten
mein job ist an die börse alter schwede
sieht geil aus sich machen haben auf 500
grad hin können er hat nichts gesehen
leute
wenn das jetzt klappen denn so will das
hätte ich nicht erwartet was dass die
sehkraft hätte ich nicht gedacht die
gardinen tomatensoße die auch entdeckte
diese koste schnell gemeinhardt
[Musik]
marschall gibt ganz europa
der sv geht obwohl ich sogar jetzt sagen
muss den rand hat sogar noch ein
bisschen mehr verbrannt gekämpft oder
also ich finde das perfekt aber ist auch
perfekt wie machen es noch perfekter bei
der zweiten dritten platz erst
kurzzeitig mal andere datei komplett
flache zweisitzer her ist doch zusammen
dass ich nicht gedacht das ist übelst
keinen vorschuss euch an der unterboden
ist auch richtig knusprig und das ist
die allerbeste selbstgemacht ist ehrlich
gesagt habe ich habe ja komplett selber
gemacht einfach das ist ja hammer
schmeckt wie bei 450 karten die
tomatensoße wie kann die so geil sein
alles schmeckt so lecker wie kann ich
tomaten müssen das ja auch noch kurz bei
den feierabend
[Musik]
im letzten abschluss noch mal eine
calzone gemacht ist auch eine lustige
erfahrung zum ersten mal damit pizza zu
backen ich fand die pizza war richtig
lecker was so auch es gibt in köln soll
an der iss 84 grad exakt genauso
gesperrt und dafür greifen weil die
machen das professionelle fast die beste
pizza der welt auf jeden fall das würde
dem titel schnitte okay ich würde sagen
wir lassen es uns auch weiter schmecken
vielen dank fürs zuschauen
es kommen bestimmt noch das ein oder
andere video das ich mit dem pizzaofen
aufnehmen und damit ein bisschen besser
wir sehen uns sagen macht's gut bis
zunächst mal lukas verlinkt ich hoffe
ich setzt die brille nicht in der 30